you pass a gas station on the way you
know they're sucking dicks down in
Emeryville
that must be tough
[Music]
this is happening in Boston you got FBI
agents doing one of those training
simulations you know where they do a
breach they go go go go get in there and
they grab a guy and they they take them
uh for they handcuff them so what
happened is they go into this hotel
where they're running the training
exercise they break into this hotel room
uh grab the dude handcuff them throw
them into the bathroom he's in the
shower I know what the [__] going on
like you you better talk and they like
try to get him to like confess and they
do everything you're supposed to do
45 minutes later of doing this they
realize it's a real guy and he's not one
of the actors that's great that's the
best meanwhile the actor is just
chilling in his room waiting he's just
chilling and he's rehearsing his lines
these amateurs are so late
like it was 45 minutes ago free dude
yeah they broke into the wrong room and
they ended up interrogating an actual
Delta pilot and what if they missed
their flying or what if they actually
got some like critical information out
of the guy yeah
[Laughter]
this just tells me that if I'm staying
at any hotel at any given time there
might be some FBI training that's really
going on while I'm watching friends or
something that's really weird that this
happens in a place where you can get the
wrong room and get an actual dude but
also aren't you guys the FBI dude
you guys are the FBI you guys can't make
these videos man they're training for a
reason you know because then this
happens
female body inspector someone was like
all right the room is
f24 and then they're dyslexic or some
[__] right it was supposed to be f-42
he told him to go to an f45
40 the gym
yeah they really uh they don't know the
Pilot's on the [__] bike and [__] oh
[__] they just take them it doesn't say
yeah who's to blame if like they are
they're to blame dude what if someone
gave them wrong number or if they read
it wrong like who's they're all to blame
so basically he's this guy's tied up in
the bathtub he thinks he's gonna [__]
die oh my God but he's like I'm just a
Delta pilot they're like [__] and
they're like hitting the script they're
like you're jealous tell us where the
bomb is right now does this act is
really good this time yeah tell us
everything this guy's not breaking yeah
and then they're like in the back
high-fiving each other like we're gonna
get [__] a pluses dude we're gonna
get [__] we're gonna go the child
makes them sound like all idiots just
the dorkiest things like human error
yeah all human errors so I didn't
realize at all that anybody was running
training exercise like that on public
like well not that this is public
property but it's like anybody could
have been in there yes so he could have
been like getting it online right one of
the Special Forces phases I think in
their qualification course goes through
a real town and that town knows but the
thing is the town can do whatever they
want to go against them what to test
them right yeah yeah so it's like like
so you cannot cooperate you cannot
cooperate and so they just part of it
and then so like uh there's literally no
rules because like you know in real in
like a real scenario there's no rules
right yeah so for them like if you if
it's freezing you can ask one of the
like uh neighbors if you can sleep in
their barn and you can literally use
anything that comes to mind to
accomplish that mission that you need to
at that in that phase of the course but
the the towns people also know that so
they can do anything that they want to
[__] with you and not make themselves
too do you think someone ever like
breaks character and they start laughing
like I'm sorry can we retake that from
Top like like oh my God I'm so sorry
yeah probably I think if I was being
interrogated I think I would break dude
could you get in trouble for like
pushing it too far like if if a guy was
like let me let me have a place to stay
and you're like yeah if you suck my dick
I think the towns people can do anything
but if you're in the Special Forces like
a qualification course you have to
follow
law on the rules damn dude everyone's
getting ahead yeah please
some Warrior lovers like live there and
then they just like oh oh they're
they're doing a simulation come on
come on oh are we in trouble officer
it's not what it looks like oh [__] you
you pass a gas station on the way you
know they're sucking dicks down at
Emeryville
that would be tough dude more special
horses guys they're like this is nothing
like what we signed up unless if they're
picking a small town you know they're
bored as hell they're like yeah I'm down
like what does this have to do with
Afghanistan
so I went down this like rabbit hole of
civilians that can take military former
military like teaching like they're
teaching all these cool like skills
right like one would be like hostage
survival like if you ever get taken
hostage what to what do you do how to
escape like when you're in a situation
and all that and these seminars are
pretty [__] sick like let's say like
and then they you could see their
itinerary it'll be like first day
lecture or whatever right yeah and then
like the final exam might be like
um you are in a hostage situation you
have to escape or like you get released
in uh an unknown location and you have
to find your way to this point or like
it's like they'll drop you off in the
middle of the city and then they
blindfold you right like you you don't
you'll like um you'll be like alone in a
hotel room and then you have to go to
like the Rendezvous point so I'm like
dude this is like [__] really cool
grown-up just games yeah
and I'm like I want to take them I want
to do that too Tim Kennedy teaches them
dude let's do Tim Kevin that's what his
whole company is let's do this because I
don't know
you'd probably love that I would love
that let's do it yeah I don't know what
I'll use any of this stuff I failed I
die I mean that's good though because
it's like survival skills too in those
type of situations if you do
accidentally get lost somehow I know but
my life is so safe did you ever have to
learn what happens when you get captured
like what you're supposed to no so that
one's like a special school I didn't get
a chance to go like in the military it's
called serious school things like
survival Escape something evasion that
one's really really cool I really wish I
signed up for it but it's like a three
week long School uh everyone has to kill
the rabbit with their bare hands they
teach you how to skin the rabbit they
teach you just crack the rabbit neck
they teach you how to like eat the
eyeball
um like eat the brain or whatever so
that you know how like if you're in the
forest any rodent like animal you know
how to eat in skin and cook so do they
just have a bunch of cage of cute little
bunnies and you just pick it up I think
so I think so and then they have one
where they they put you in a box like
this for like 17 hours a little box yeah
so you know what it feels like to be in
a hostage situation you just have to
[__] and piss in a box wait how many
hours 717 that's part of it and there's
another one where um because a bunch of
people at my unit went to it and I wish
I did it I was like well and I wish I
did can you poop and pee in the Box you
have to but on yourself yeah it's on
yourself and there's another one where
they drop you off in the forest and then
you have to make your way to the
Rendezvous point but the instructors are
also in the forest so they're gonna whip
your ass if they catch you so you you
you're just gonna get an ass whooping
because they can they're so good and you
suck so bad yeah so they're just gonna
find it so it's just up to you to make
sure like you get your less ass
whoopings and try to make it to the
Rendezvous dude that'd be so scary
you're just walking through a forest you
can punch at the [__] face yeah if
that's and that might even be like that
might be a yeah yeah
like when you're going through the
forest you might be like this is like ah
this is pepper sprays [__]
oh [__] oh [__] yeah dude that sounds so
scary but like probably once you've
finished all that you probably you're
like dude I'm so ready like kidnap me
yeah you're like bro I wish somebody was
kidnap me how else are you gonna learn
yeah that's right it's like y'all learn
from experience you gotta go through the
stress right what's like what's like one
of the I guess like main things that to
remember if you get captured by the
enemy in terms of like if you're a
prisoner fart and then distract them
yeah bring attention bring attention and
then they're like oh they're like oh and
then you run parts are fun so like the
basic stuff that I know is at the point
of capture that is your highest chance
of survival so the minute you are
captured or getting detained you need to
fight for your life and make as much
noise in a scene as possible because the
minute you go on the van the van gets on
the road yeah something goes over your
head you don't know where you're going
your chances of getting discovered and
surviving is very slim so as soon as
someone grabs you before like you're
getting literally pulled underwater you
need to do whatever you can get the [__]
out so like in movies when when you see
a guy like they come around the back and
they go gotcha and then the whole unit
goes like this that's never a thing that
happens like they just fight till the
last possible moment it depends because
if it's in that situation then you kind
of have to zoom out and all of their
like snipers where you can't make noise
because then it gives away your position
so it depends on a lot of context you
know like are you secretly doing
something because they didn't feel like
to make noise
[Laughter]
I took the Tactical medical uh medical
course from sheepdog and it was dope
like after your lecture and you're in
like the lab part then you do a bunch of
like stress scenarios so you know what
it feels like so they go okay you guys
are hanging out you guys are at the bank
or whatever so everyone's just kind of
role playing and then some guy was going
like bang bang bang bang uh you guys are
dead you two are in charge go so right
from the start you have to like like you
can't just go
no you hit me
I dodged it
Johnny ended the whole thing out into
the parking lot so now like this guy's
dead weight we pick him up we throw them
in the truck we drive down the truck we
actually make phone calls and stuff it
was pretty cool like right here you're
not getting this truth
you treat it like
can you imagine they're all [__]
you're all disagreeable you're all
fighting you just keep going no no
before you're like Neil from The Matrix
you're playing this whole character oh
he's new he's Neo got it got it Tim he's
like dude what the [__] are you doing
he's just trying to teach a course he
goes all right you're dead you're dead
you're dead and you're just like no I I
dodged it you think Jim Kennedy would
would have any of that or would just be
like get the [__] out Tim is because
he's like a kid kind of right be like I
shot you back
you'll [__] around but he'll end up
probably just like choking you out while
he's laughed like you stupid ass still
get punished he's like if you want to
[__] around we can [__] around but my
[__] around is deadly yeah didn't you
say he was like grappling you and like
poking your ass or something yeah he was
like we're grappling and then like uh we
did a grappling scenario I had a I had
the gun he had the knife so he had the
uh handicap right within seconds my gun
is out of my hands and he's like jamming
me in my [__] [__] the whole
[__] time
and he's [__] making love to me like
biting me on the neck and I'm like oh
[__] and there's nothing you can do
nothing I could do and you can feel that
there's no way out literally nothing I
can do yeah except just enjoy it haha
[Music]